[Music]
okay let's learn the reals when you take
any of your same time turns like up
behind the hips and then passing up in
front of the hips
if you loop that that's the tip reals
if you loop down behind the shoulders
with down in front of the shoulders that
shoulder reels and if you loop up on the
hips with down behind the shoulders
that's chase the Sun I don't know where
these names came from they all happen
you know there was all named before I
started spinning quite and there's a few
hints and tricks still learning to do
this well it first starts with how
you're turning so face this with me now
up till now we have been working with
cardinal directions so directly in front
of me I've got the middle of the bridge
directly to my right I've got a tree
direct with my left I've got it
unfortunately and directly behind me
I've got you and and what we're doing
now we're gonna pick some stuff in
between the Cardinals so because if
you're doing a full turn I can face the
tree and then I can turn 180 degrees
towards the oil Pinker and that works
great and then maybe I do another full
turn to my left get back to my tree but
if you're trying to loop this as reals
turning my body all the way from the
tree to my oil tanker is kind of
oversteering it's a bit chaotic it's
hard to control so my sternum my body
I'm just going to turn well there's my
middle of my bridge I'm just going to
turn from the grain elevator to the
container ship so it's more of just a
wiggle
but the poi the tracks don't change and
this this is the funny thing so what you
need to do is get your poi coming down
your landmark to your right but then
shift your body back towards the front
so I should probably halfway back
towards the middle of the bridge and
when I'm from over here the player going
backwards up my oil tanker but I shift
my sternum half way back towards know
the bridge
so for me it's going between the grain
elevator and the blue shipping buildings
so this and I didn't start just with the
turns in front of you so I start here I
shift my body when I turn I just shift
right a little bit my pores are coming
up the oil tanker but my sternums facing
on an angle over here I'm gonna shift
back turn and back turn and then I find
what's a minimal amount of a wiggling of
turning with my body that makes a turn
happen I want it to happen from the
turning because this will look really
awkward then you're gonna do the same
thing the poi coming behind you so again
normally you would start here but now
you're gonna shift your body back
towards the front and up behind you with
a little turn and then down behind your
shoulders with a little turn up behind
with a little turn down behind up behind
until you can do this one and this one
with just a slight shifting of your
shoulders
now let's look at let's start with a
shield rules so we start with the pull
over here but our bodies shifted back to
where it's not wobbly but towards the
front we do a little turn at the body
just pass the POI
down past your toes and then a little
turn back tiny shoulders toes shoulders
toes shoulders toes shoulders toes and
you might have to go to practice that
for a while come back and you're gonna
do this we're gonna go shoulders toes
all-in-one shoulders shift back shift
over and back and once that works you
can try shoulders and back and the
shoulders and back shoulders and toes
shoulders and toes shoulders and toes
shoulders and then you can try ask the
toes behind the shoulders toes behind
the shoulders toes behind the shoulders
toes and that shoulder wheels so see how
that's just a little bit of the minimal
amount of wiggling possible at the hips
is going to be the same thing instead of
a full turn like this you're going to
already have your body facing the front
and you're just going to do a slight
shift with your hips and then rain one
front with a bit of a turn behind in
front behind in front and you look for
as little turning as possible but using
the turn and then you think behind hips
in front as one movement behind hips
front or you can go from front to behind
the hips front to behind the hips front
behind the hips front behind the hips
we're gonna come back to this next in
the next section the next week because
it's going to take a bit to build this
up but that that will get you started
it's okay of civil shaky we're gonna
start here we're going to continue and
they get you really smooth with all of
this
[Music]